we need to write a role for Bobby Lee I
actually wrote it I was like and they
were like and they like what is this
character WR like I have this idea for
this part and it's really funny I was
like it should be Bobby Lee I think just
putting him in this movie in this world
would be so much fun so when the strike
is resolved and things are done we can
talk about it more open it but it was a
pleasurable experience but you were
great to work with Bobby really thank
you and it was it was a dreamy
experience and I want to just I just
want to say that out loud you know I
like that I'm not nervous anymore I'm
not nervous anymore I look at you I'm
like uh you're
like you're like now when you open your
mouth I think I could even [__] in that
mouth not intimidating